in this video I want to talk about
hemoglobin right again revs:824rpm 11
which is a previous HB F ok and how all
these sort of play in together the gram
scheme of things
okay so in the last video I mentioned
allosteric regulation when I talked
about hemoglobin right I mentioned I
mentioned this idea of allosteric
regulation and cooperativity
specifically now allosteric regulation
again is just as a brief sort of
definition is the whole idea that the
binding at one subunit of a
multi-subunit protein can have an effect
at the other subunits of as far as
affinity of that before that ligand goes
so there is the case of course that when
one oxygen binds a particular subunit
the other subunits have an increased
affinity for oxygen now there are other
things that can bind hemoglobin that
will actually reduce the affinity of
hemoglobin for oxygen so there there are
three things that I want to mention so
there is h plus right which is just
protons there is carbon dioxide and
there is this thing called 2 3 this
phospho phospho glycerate otherwise
known as 2 3 BPG ok now all of these
things here all of them they all reduce
hemoglobins affinity for oxygen now how
how do they do that ok so
um hemoglobin this is something I didn't
mention in the other video hemoglobin
has two states that can be stabilized
okay there are two states there are is
the our state or the relaxed State okay
so hemoglobin can be relaxed or it can
be in the T state which is the tight or
taut state or taut taut state okay what
do you need to know about these two
states well essentially what you need to
know is that the our state has a high
affinity for oxygen okay it binds oxygen
tightly the T state has a low affinity
for oxygen okay so it actually releases
oxygen so this is this binds Oh too
tightly and this one releases oxygen
okay so now if all three of these things
here right if protons carbon dioxide and
two three BP g if they're all reducing
high MacGuffins affinity for oxygen what
they're doing is that they are
stabilizing the T State okay so all
these all three of these things right
they stabilize the T State l vemma
globin okay so let's talk about sort of
how this works okay
numbering each one at a time okay so
let's do let's do proton monster so um
concentration essentially what happens
is that if we have if we have hemoglobin
bound to oxygen right which we kind of
denote like this HBO - if we add H
pluses right protons we shift the
equilibrium to end up having this which
what we get is if we if we add enough
protons what ends up happening is that
the the protons end up binding the
hemoglobin and then the hemoglobin
releases the oxygens okay so just a shot
liaison supported general chemistry is
that if you add a bunch enough Prout
enough of one enough of a particular
reagent to one side of the reaction you
will shift the reaction to the other
side so if we add enough protons here
we'll shift the reaction this way so as
to stabilize the t-state of hemoglobin
causing it to release oxygen okay so
essentially what we're trying to talk
about here is that excuse me is that as
pH actually is before I mention pH as H+
concentration increases right we favor
the T State we have more hemoglobin in
the T state right so what that means is
that more oxygen is released okay now um
pH increases are the same at or Salemi I
think I might've just I don't know I
just said let me just say it again H+
concentration increases is the same
thing right this is the same thing as ap
creepy LP crease a PhD crease okay so a
PhD crease is the same thing as a H+
increase right so decreased pH increased
H+ concentration causes more of the
hemoglobin to exist in the T State and
more oxygen is released so when does
this sort of this concept come into play
hmm excuse me
um actively metabolizing muscles for
instance actively metabolizing muscles
have have lactic acid buildup now what
is that you might have heard of you know
when you exercise you get like soreness
in your muscles that soreness is due to
lactic acid buildup the details behind
that I'm not - imperative right now the
whole idea is that if you have lactic
acid buildup
then the amino acid to give up their
protons right this will increase H+
concentration decrease the pH and you
know we have more hemoglobin in the
t-state so we end up with oxygen being
released from him from you go clubbin
okay the second thing carbon dioxide how
does that work
okay what happens there well if you
recall in the past we mentioned this
sort of reaction okay this whole idea
that that we can have carbon dioxide
plus water yielding carbonic acid
carbonic acid which will dissociate into
H+ and bicarbonate ion right the enzyme
that does this reaction I think I
mentioned it before in a previous video
is called carbon carbonic anhydrase in
any case what we talked about before is
that if we increase the amount of carbon
dioxide the reaction will shift so as to
create more H+ ions right so more carbon
dioxide equals more H+ right which is
just the same thing as a decreased pH
again same idea more hemoglobin is in
the t-state
right so more oxygen is released so it's
sort of the same idea as above
as mentioned above okay another thing is
that actively metabolizing cells create
co2 via cellular respiration right this
is something we'll mention later but
this uh if you recall we breathe in
oxygen right into our enemy that our
cells use up oxygen and then we breathe
out carbon dioxide before we can breathe
out that carbon dioxide that carbon
dioxide exists in our tissues so cells
that are actively metabolizing oxygen
are creating a bunch of co2 right so if
this is if we're actively metabolizing
cells are gonna have a lot of co2 then
that's going to lead to a lot of H
pluses which is going to cause the
oxygen to be released to those to those
cells and that makes perfect sense to
write if if our cells are are actively
metabolizing they're doing a lot of work
they need a lot of oxygen right so we
want to make sure that when the
hemoglobin gets to our tissues that
there is a high concentration of co2
that causes the oxygen to be released to
our tissues so our tissues can use them
okay so hopefully that makes sense there
okay now um let me sort of break that
down in a little chart before I actually
get to the depth to discussing 2/3 BPG
so um essentially what we got here is
we've got we've got lungs right our
lungs and we've got actively
metabolizing tissues right so in our
lungs in our lungs we have a high pH
right um high pH relative to the act
actively metabolizing tissues right here
we have lower PHS right and due to the
production
of h+ is right in every right in the two
ways to listed above okay so now um this
makes sense why does this make sense
well because in our lungs right we want
hemoglobin to bind oxygen right so we
want there to be a high pH we don't want
a low pH there if there's a low pH there
that means hemoglobin can't bind oxygen
there's a high pH then hemoglobin binds
the oxygen right here the low pH causes
hemoglobin to release releases the
oxygen okay which is what we want in the
lungs we want we breathe in oxygen we
want the hemoglobin to bind the oxygen
then we want that that hemoglobin to
take that oxygen to our cells right or
our tissue actively metabolizing tissues
I want that o2 to be released to watch
issues okay so in the lungs
or there's a high pH right
hemoglobin releases the H plusses right
whereas here in actively metabolizing
tissues hemoglobin binds those protons
okay hopefully that sort of wraps things
up and makes sense overall in terms of
our physiology okay the third thing is
the third thing is of course 2/3 BPG all
right - 3 BPG is the structure here let
me actually draw this out for you so 2/3
BPG looks like this it's got carboxyl
group and then the CH o phosphate group
here with this negative these negative
charges and then it also has ch2 and
then another phosphate group okay this
this is 2/3 B Fiji ok so what we notice
about 2/3 be Fiji well it's got a lot of
negative charges ok so this is important
okay the reason why is because 2/3 BPG
what it does is it binds or
interacts with positive positively
charged things okay right what have we
be talking about that can be positively
charged in hemoglobin
well amino acids right basic amino acids
we mentioned histidine right being being
in our sidechain in you know in these
heme groups right so ends up happening
is that two or three BPG can bind the
positively charged histidine right or
even lysines right that are you know but
other basic amino acids that are in the
hemoglobin okay because these negative
charges are attracted to these positive
charges because opposite charges attract
right so two three BPG right will bind
and we set up up earlier that it
inhibits the hemoglobin from from
functioning so again two three BPG right
when it does this it alters the
confirmation of of hemoglobin oops
confirmation sorry about that
confirmation of hemoglobin right
specifically it stabilizes the T state
right again causing Oh to release okay
so if there's a lot of to three BPG
around with o2 is released if there
isn't very much around oh to is bound
and it's actually excuse me a very
important allosteric regulator of of
hemoglobin function okay now I also
mention so this actually I mentioned up
here that I wanted to talk about the
Bohr effect this whole concept here is
like everything that I've mentioned from
here sort of through what I just
finished talking about is kind of the
Bohr effect the whole idea behind these
dallas jag regulation of hemoglobin
okay now what I want to talk about is
fetal hemoglobin and how that comes into
play
let me scroll down just a little bit
more so what are the things that we need
to know about fetal hemoglobin okay
let's bring in a new color I don't know
let's just do a baby blue since we're
talking about babies so fetal hemoglobin
fetal hemoglobin HB f is how it's sort
of abbreviated fetal hemoglobin fetal
hemoglobin I'm just going to straight-up
say it that it has a higher affinity for
oxygen than maternal any bug weapon has
a higher affinity for oxygen then
maternal hemoglobin or just hemoglobin
all right this is just HB okay in case
it's not clear adult hemoglobin is just
maternal he will open okay why is this
the reason for this the reason for this
is because because fetal hemoglobin has
a lower affinity a lower affinity for
2/3 BPG why why does the why is that the
case okay so we're going to talk about
in just a second okay and so um I would
do want to note though before I started
to explain things is that its function
is to deliver oxygen from the mother to
the fetus right to a pregnant mothers
fetus okay so now I just mentioned that
that it has a higher affinity for oxygen
than maternal hemoglobin because
hemoglobin the fetal hemoglobin has a
lower affinity for 2 3 B G so what is
what is going on there okay so let's
let's mention this let's mention more
details about fetal hemoglobin fetal
hemoglobin excuse me
it's structure it also has four
polypeptide chains okay but instead of
alpha 2 to alpha groups and two beta
groups what it has is two alpha groups
and to gamma groups to gamma sub chain a
site between T sub units two alpha
subunits to gamma subunits okay and that
this is what makes it different than
then adult hemoglobin okay so it binds
this to 3b fiji more weakly okay because
it binds this more weakly what has that
sort of work right well what was what is
the difference there um we said that 2 3
d PG is an inhibitor of hemoglobin
function right so if this essentially
means that if you're binding less to 3
BPG right that means you're inhibited
less right so so 2 3 b PG doesn't have
as drastic an effect on fetal hemoglobin
as it does on maternal hemoglobin so it
is less inhibited then maternal
hemoglobin okay which if it's less
inhibited that means that it can bind to
oxygen better it's quite simply right so
so why is this why can I do that well
this is this is the sort of the boom
here okay these gamma subunits right
what's going on there is that a serine
residue right which is a polar but
neutral right a polar neutral amino acid
is substituted right substituted in
place of a histidine which is a polar
but positively charged amino acid right
so what's going on here what's what's
what's the deal quite simply is that
this negative charge right the negative
charge
of 2-3 BPG is more attracted to the
positive charge of histidine right than
it is to the neutral the neutral serine
right okay so essentially what happens
is that 2 3 v VG cannot bind fetal
hemoglobin as tightly as it can material
hemoglobin so fetal hemoglobin is not
inhibited in the way that maternal
hemoglobin is so it has a higher
affinity and just to show you how that
would look on the on the o2 saturation
curve if we have maternal hemoglobin it
kind of looks like this actually last
time I drew it in for though might as
well draw it blue this time so maternal
hemoglobin looks a little bit like this
right if this is maternal hemoglobin
right and of course these these axes are
still labeled as the pressure of oxygen
and the percent saturation right fetal
hemoglobin of course in the baby blue
would be shifted to the left right of
maternal hemoglobin because it has a
higher affinity right it takes it
doesn't take it doesn't need as high a
pressure of oxygen to become more
saturated so for instance here again
just a sort of quick example is that if
we have let's say this here is uh I
don't know like ten let's just say it's
20 tours of pressure right if this is
50% this is like 100% up here these are
just numbers I'm making up at this point
but at 20 tours hemoglobin right is less
than
serrated right then fetal hemoglobin
right fetal hemoglobin might be at like
25% maybe
and whereas hemoglobin will only be I
don't know maybe around 10% the whole
idea is that fetal hemoglobin can be at
a higher level of saturation at a lower
concentration of oxygen which means that
it has a higher affinity I hope that
video is helpful see you next time